we are pleased to inform you that you
have been accepted at Hogwarts School of
Witchcraft and Wizardry
all right so we're gonna be retro
okay name already exists
oh my gosh okay what if we try like
all caps
does that matter
oh he took that yes
and the experience was Unforgettable
looks like I drove a little too fast for
you
actually doesn't look too bad on screen
what you guys are seeing
whoa
wait wait which one do we tap here
that one that one
I don't want to jinx anything but if
we're retro with all caps then that
means it just it just automatically
pulled it in
I could actually watch
I have the game being displayed on like
three screens right now it's kind of
crazy
I could just watch it being played up
here
okay let's take a look at your task
tracker metamalkin's new robe
have a makeover at Madame malkins all
right
tap to enter so we just tap on over here
to the right
I'll do that loading was quick
oh I'm just so happy we finally got it
working dude let's go let's go
75 minutes in
don't even care
all right you can alter your appearance
later for free witches and wizards
cannot share a dormitory so please
choose carefully
so these are just like little presets
here and then we
then we take it from there
all right so that
uh I feel like I'm closer to this
this guy
oh wait this isn't where we set our
change our character
or is this what we're about to do
yeah here we go
all right
okay
dude is it all
long hair options no way right
I need something that suits my style
okay so these are it says accessories
wait how do I go back
[Music]
so is this it is it just like these
presets
yeah yeah not only do I have the game
running we've got a great story that's
true
you can change your face okay so you do
that
not at this screen right
I think I have to go I have to confirm
and go on over
all right dude you gotta be kidding me
with these
school perhaps the changes in order
well I guess we're gonna have to be like
16 year old retro
when I had a lot more hair than I do now
let's go
that one that's kind of how I used to
style my hair actually
and
definitely wasn't black yeah kind of
like a dark
[Music]
yeah go with the dark brown
no ball to lever I mean they're no like
closely shaven you know
okay so this is a skin
[Music]
okay so that's controlling the face
right there all right so that's option
one
option two
option three
option four
that option four I feel like I'll let
you guys help me chat what which one you
think looks most like me
definitely not that one
oh definitely not and then that's the
last one not that one either I mean none
of them look like exactly like me but I
feel like that might be closest right
this this is option four
no beards no way it's Hogwarts Legacy
all over again okay so let's go through
them there's one
two
three
four which is the one that I I'm
personally leaning to five
six
seven
eight
nine
and then ten perhaps it changes in order
that's five
Roger said five
so that's five
that's four yeah the lips are bigger on
that one but the nose I feel like this
one matches my nose better
this one matches my lips better
hahaha
oh dude I need something that suits my
style
another four
Jared says five oh man
all right well we're all in I agree
these are definitely like the two
closest
another four Lauren with a four
I'm gonna go with four
all right that for hair okay yeah eyes
are blue
perhaps are changes in order
oh wait what is this this is where you
change oh so you can actually change
your eyebrows this is just the color
okay
I need something that suits my style
something that suits my style
pupil pattern what doesn't look like we
have any other options on that one right
now
okay this is like uh
freckles moles
okay no on that
and then glasses nah
oh although if I did Rock with glasses I
would pick that one I do wear glasses
sometimes but majority of time I don't
all right confirm
I was wondering that Jenny if if there
were more options later on
oh
maybe I should go okay for me definite
no on that one
[Music]
definite no on that one I'm either
number one or number three
that's number one
that's number three
I think we go with number three oh Roger
said one
Lauren said one all right all right all
right we'll go with one we'll let the
let Chad help us out
shall we oh no then we had three threes
it's all good idea shop is very close
you'll see